I know all the fat acceptance rhetoric
and I know why it's not true
mind you
I'm talking about my experiences
these people literally are like foaming at the mouth to try and find me and catch me in a lie
to try and catch other fat people
like in this big lie
because they have this belief that all fat people
people who are fat acceptance people are like
lying and we're trying to like
manipulate our audience or whatever
and it's like I I know where these people are coming from like
these anti fat acceptance like
Youtubers or pages or like
literally whatever
because they all say the same thing when they come into my page
and they all do this thing where they genuinely
they think that everything that I'm saying is a lie
mind you I am literally just speaking about my experience
I'm literally just trying to live in the world as a fat person
I'm trying to be okay and comfortable in my body
and these people genuinely get so angry because they
they are made to think they are manipulating
into thinking that I am some manipulative person that is lying
and that I'm not actually confident
that I actually hate myself
and I'm trying to what
manipulate people into being okay with their body or oh
promote obesity which like
what does that mean if you wanna worry about someone promoting obesity
get mad at the food industry
United States
at all the corn syrup in our food
at all the corporations that are literally
like pouring sugar into everything that we eat
don't get mad at me when I talk
I'm not saying I want you to become fatter
my goal is to make you fat
literally my only goal is to make people okay in the bodies that they exist in
I just want you to be happy as you are
and that is literally
literally all I wanna do
that's it sorry
I have no interest in hating my body for the rest of my life
I apologize if that's an inconvenience for you
but your feelings are not my problem